hi good evening ladies and gentlemen my
name is janine
and i'm from the design singapore
council i'll be your mcm moderator today
thank you for joining us for our webinar
to our city with love
which is the third in this series
these webinars are held as part of the
lovable singapore project
led by the design singapore council and
our partners
the center for liveable cities deloitte
center for the edge
the housing and development board
national university
of singapore's school of design and
environment
participate in design and the urban
redevelopment authority
in support of the singapore together
movement
this event is also part of the national
design center's program
lineup for april and may with a thematic
focus on
passing hope so this evening's program
is in two parts
the first will be a sharing by the
project team
so larry from participate in design will
be talking about the design approach and
methodology behind the study
and afterwards we will be sharing some
initial findings from the study
part two of the webinar will be a panel
discussion
on designing for a post-pandemic lovable
singapore
as well as designing a sense of agency
and ownership
all throughout you are welcome to drop
your questions in the join a box
if there are unanswered questions we
will address them in the last
open q a segment
so first to start us off i would like to
invite mr marquis executive director
of the design singapore council to give
us some opening remarks
mark leads the council in driving and
implementing national policies on design
as ds3 continues on its design
2025 journey which is to make singapore
an innovation-driven economy
and a livable city by design an
award-winning design veteran with
white industry connections mark has
brought the work of the council to the
attention of
global design leaders via platforms such
as
brainstorm design milan design week and
the international architecture
exhibition please welcome mark
hey janine um anyway i
i think it's for everyone dialing in um
good evening everyone
welcome to our webinar um to our city of
love
this is really a third of our three-part
series exploring
what a lovable singapore means to us and
um
i'm mark and i'm very happy to welcome
such a wonderful and diverse audience
from singapore and
beyond i understand that today we
actually have guests
from um from east and southeast asia
australia and various parts of europe as
well so thank you
to everyone for just joining us this
evening um i know a number of y'all
might be joining us for the first time
so i'll just take a few minutes to
introduce design singapore council and
what we do
um as the national agency for design our
vision actually is for singapore to be
an innovation driven economy
and a lovable city through design two
quite distinctive but very meaningful
kind of objectives
we have organizations and enterprises
use design as a strategy to grow your
business
and deliver people-centered public
services
nurture industry-ready talent and enable
a design-minded workforce for the future
economy
but we also promote the singapore brand
through raising design and appreciation
on ground
and making emotional connections with
peoples of people across the world for
example through this webinar
i'm personally excited to introduce the
topic of our webinar today which is
about how we can come together to design
a lovable singapore
and this is an important milestone for
us as it is
our first public sharing of the insights
from a long research study in the area
of livability
in singapore involving more than 2 300
respondents
generating over 9000 minutes of
engagement and insights and hotly
discussed
with multiple partners at this point i
think earlier janine
i gave a shout out to our project
partners the ura
hdb clc center for liverpool city sorry
i know there's a lot of acronyms
sg together the national university of
singapore
uh deloitte center for the age and uh
participate
in design and you'll be hearing from
some of them later at the panel
discussion
through our study in the loveable
singapore project we have heard many
stories
some early insights some surprising some
inspiring and a few
funny and heartwarming ones we heard
about how the fast-paced transformation
of singapore's landscape
has affected its people's sense of
connection with the history and places
of singapore
how urbanization leads to the new
breathing spaces and how certain
space typologies actually offer users a
sense of freedom by being inclusive and
authentic
we also heard from the 2300 respondents
we surveyed
what they found lovable or unlovable
about our local identity
relationship with institutions and
fellow singaporean residents
apparently being law abiding scored
pretty high on our list
to my surprise and we are looking
forward to sharing this and more
insights and stories with you in this
webinar
two questions we hope to explore in
today's webinar
will help to shape what the future
lovable city
could look like one and how can we
design loveability
for a post-covert world and related to
that how can we use design and design
tools to actually foster a sense of
ownership and agency amongst people
the answers to these questions are
important not just to singapore but also
we believe to the rest of the world
and today more as today more than half
of the world's population lives in urban
areas and
as you know by 2050 two-thirds of the
global population
will actually do so according to the
united nations
along with that cities are facing
increasingly complex
problems like climate change the aging
population economic recession
as a result of geopolitical
uncertainties and not to mention of
course the severe consequence that the
global pandemic has had on our urban
society and economy
so we feel strongly that the solutions
to these challenges will be driven by
people who love the places they live in
and who have a stake in actually
improving the lives of their communities
and environment
and in the coming months we'll be
working with with partner agencies to
run focus
groups and programs to actually find
actionable solutions through our
insights
and you're very welcome to sign up so
please keep a lookout for details at the
end of the session
we are also very excited to gather our
panelists from diverse backgrounds
across public
private and academic sectors and they
spend much of their careers thinking and
working
on creating loveability and finally i'm
sure our speakers tonight will agree
with me
we are keen to hear from you our
audience
through the polls and q a we hope that
this session will be interactive
candid and open so i warmly invite you
to participate with your views tonight
and with this i would like to hand over
the time to our research team and
panelists
and i wish everyone of course a very
lovable evening
so thank you so now let's kick off the
sharing
with larry from participate in design so
how does one design
a study on loveability what is the
approach that was taken what kind of
challenges and learning points were
there
we have been working with participate in
design on this project for more than a
year
so larry executive director has
a lot of learning points to share on
what the participatory approach and
methodologies taken to shape
a study on loveability could be
larry over to you thanks janine and hi
a very good evening to everybody my name
is larry
i'm executive director for participating
in design
and of course i'm really really excited
to share you know the whole journey of
talking about lovability of singapore
yeah so i think for us we really started
off the research with two main
questions right what do people love
about singapore
and what will make singap what will make
people love singapore more
now if i were to just throw this name
about loveability to all of you
it's quite challenging right when we
first started off talking to our you
know 60 year old grandma
or 40 year old auntie what does
lovability mean
we i mean we you know they do not know
how to respond you know i think as
asians you know we don't really talk
about love livability yes you know
quality of life satisfaction yes but
what exactly is lovability what is love
for a city
yeah so i think for us we really want to
know what exactly
is lovability in singapore what do our
daily singaporeans and everyday people
define
love right and what are some of the
interventions that um
you know we can actually go about doing
to make this place more lovable
and what are some framework and
methodology that we use for this study
so i think like i said you know we do
not want the study to just be
you know limited to a group of experts
or academics we really want to hear from
everyday people
from all walks of life what exactly does
lovability mean to you
and i think even though it was the
pandemic i'm really very pleased
we are still many we managed to engage
around 2400 residents
with almost over 50 000 you know
engagement minutes for this entire study
which i will share a little bit more
what we did so i think
you know it's always very challenging to
have a study like that because
how do we balance the viewpoints of
academics with our partner agencies with
our everyday people
because everybody has so many different
definitions of
love right so i think what we did in the
first phase in the connect and framing
phase was really to look at all the
studies around the world
um we really want to understand right
what what it means to be
you know to actually talk about when we
talk about lovability in business
and in the lens of creative industry so
i think dsg done some focus group
discussion to get these people to talk
about what are their definition of love
and they this gave us a little bit of
basic understanding of what lovability
means
in the so-called you know creative
sector and business sector
and we have asked more questions as well
through our leisure review right what is
our favorite place on earth
on a rating of one to ten how lovable is
singapore there are a lot of similar
studies done
overseas so make sure i took reference
from them to set the context of what we
feel
love is all about and with this initial
study
and this initial understanding we
actually went to test out you know with
a group of um you know selected
individuals
which um range across you know domestic
helpers
persons with disabilities and seniors uh
we tested out this with them
and then we also went into this what we
call deep dive interviews
um with what we call um
the extreme users right people who are
not your mainstream community but yet
they may have a viewpoint about love
we went to talk to them to try to
understand them and these also include
your foreign workers
you know single mothers or lgbtq
community
um we also talk to experts because we do
realize the importance of academics and
the experts in this field to get their
viewpoint as well
and with this whole holistic view on
love
we will then be able to frame more
questions
and more curated viewpoints to reach out
to the bigger community which is in our
next stage
so in our qualitative stage um we
designed our various engagement channels
right that actually includes um talking
about
uh to me singapore is whereby we get
residents to just share with us very
quickly
what they feel singapore is like to them
we also do this online copy talk
whereby because we can't do physical
engagement due to due to the pandemic
um we actually went to engage with
different people from different walks of
life
and surprisingly we have a lot of tech
savvy seniors as well who joined us
who also managed to share with us
perspective of other seniors who are not
tech savvy
so that was actually quite interesting
uh we also had this thing called the
online show and tell to run a very
in-depth qualitative survey
with different people from different
walks of life as well
and right now we are very pleased to be
at this stage whereby um
we actually did some milieu findings
whereby we went out
on a quantitative survey with 2000 over
singaporeans
um to verify and validate some of the
findings that we found out
and i think later on um janine of course
will share with you a lot of interesting
findings that we found out
and i think you guys can't wait to
actually hear from janine
but before i pass it over to janine i
would just like to again
echo what mark has said earlier as well
we will be having a lot of co-creation
sessions to have
actionable solutions to really co-create
these solutions with you so if you can
scan the qr code over there i think you
can take a look at the different dates
of the different workshops so do sign up
with us
all right and without further ado i'll
pass the time over back to janine
who will share with you all our very
interesting findings and heartwarming
stories that we hear from the ground
so janine over to you thanks larry
okay great so now on to the findings
of the surveys that we ran from october
to march
i'm actually here to share the
highlights of the survey the full report
will be out in
june but for now we want to show you
some a snapshot of how people have
responded to our surveys
and also get your inputs to the findings
so as larry has mentioned the topic of
livability is quite broad and somewhat
nebulous
so we had to use an initial framing
phase of the study
to scope the study into uh you know
manageable themes
and this has helped us to identify four
main themes
through which we ran the subsequent
surveys so we looked at spaces
identity and culture people and behavior
and relationship with public
institutions we were then able to ask
our survey respondents more
targeted questions around these things
okay so first what did people tell us
about lovable spaces
in our quantitative survey done with um
2000 people
as larry mentioned 45 percent
said that lovable spaces must most
importantly
allow them to spend time with their
loved one loved ones
this resonated more with the younger
respondents especially the 16 to 25 age
group
but also the above 55 age group
um 40 told us that they must be able to
take a breather
and this the answer is quite uh was
spread quite equally across all age
groups
so in the interest of time we have
highlighted the top five lovability
factors
out of many um i'm just going to talk
about the first two
so that we have enough time to delve
into the panel discussion afterwards
but if you have questions on the other
factors please feel free to drop them
in the q a
so doing a qualitative interview
actually helped us to uncover more
nuance and details on
um why people uh felt why people
answered the way they did previously
so throughout qualitative interviews we
also
saw that the importance of social
connection
not just with one's social circle but
also the opportunity to encounter other
people
is very important and also during the
circuit breaker i think breathing spaces
became all the more important
especially as a physical and
psychological
escape in singapore's high density
living
so we've got some quotes here from
participants
in our qualitative interviews uh here
there's a lady talking about the ulu
pandan
connector which makes her feel like
everything is back to normal it's a
place that she goes to
to get away from daily life
in terms of unlovable spaces i think um
the reasons are quite self-explanatory
most of them focus around
this amenities and poor maintenance
inconsiderate behavior was felt most
strongly amongst
respondents in their 40s and above
however our qualitative interviews
brought out more
interesting nuances so besides this
amenities from the lack of considerate
usage
during the interviews people also told
us that this amenities are poor
facilities for
those with different needs so you can
see here an
example about someone who felt concerned
for her friend
who needed wheelchair access but was
unable to get one
we also heard from people about um not
liking
faces that lack character and charm
and quite interestingly uh there was
there were quite a lot of mentions about
malls and orchard road
okay so when asked about lovable aspects
of singapore
identity and culture the clear front
runner was about the food culture
also about singapore's a multicultural
and acceptance of cultural diversity
although i should point out that uh when
we broke down the data
we could see that the under 35 year old
respondents
actually tended to disagree with this
second point more
whereas the older respondents agreed
more than the average
actually um being accepting of
cultural diversity was brought up during
our qualitative surveys
as a point of pride frequently
with interviewees telling us that seeing
different cultures being celebrated
actually made singapore feel more
lovable to them
and also food singlish the heartland way
of life
we could see that they function as a
clear uniquely singapore cultural marker
and therefore um as a social glue for
many
in terms of unlovable aspects
the quantitative survey was also very
clear i would say that out of the top
five we can see that the first four
actually
centers around livability issues and
perhaps unhappiness around income
inequalities
this was especially prominent amongst
the
25 to 45 age group
even the fifth factor unleveled around
unlovable singaporean characteristics
also tends to be um centered around
you know things like competitiveness
being kyasu or
afraid to lose
so let's see what respondents told us
about lovable
people and lovable behavior in singapore
as mark mentioned interestingly being
law abiding
came up tops by far
so this is this was a factor voted
amongst an entire
long list of factors uh given to
respondents
uh that is most important for
look in in terms of livable behavior in
singapore
the next three i would say are around
building
strong social bonds and community
networks
so having positive relationships is
clearly very important to us
and as well as having empathy and civic
mindedness i think we have to further
unpack why being law abiding is so
important to loveability
uh it could possibly have something to
do with
being mindful of the social contract and
being considerate to other people
which are points that we saw mentioned
earlier
especially in terms of use of space okay
so so here we have the
results from the qualitative survey
which
which talked about acts of kindness and
care
in micro communities especially in the
neighborhood
as well as showing spontaneity and
openness and interacting with people
that we encounter in public so again
this uh relates to the point about
uh showing friendliness and openness not
just with to your own social circle
but also uh beyond and that's
an important factor in lovability to our
respondents
so on the flip side unlovable behavior
uh the top uh the topmost factor was
about being judgmental and close
minded and then afterwards being
inconsiderate
um both in both within one's
neighborhood as well as
in public spaces being competitive and
being unfriendly so i think we can see
some
repetitive themes coming up
yeah uh this is from our qualitative
interviews
which again uh repeat which again bring
up the same points about
considerate behavior and i think this
this point comes up quite a lot because
of the
realities of high density urban living
in which
one person's behavior actually has a big
impact on other people
okay the last theme that
we asked our respondents about centers
around their relationships with public
institutions
so we defined public institutions not
just
in terms of government agencies but also
with schools
so what respondents told us is most
lovable
about public institutions is this sense
of security
being well taken care of and a sense of
trustworthiness
so you can see here that the qualitative
interviews actually echoed
what um respondents and the quantitative
surveys have said
which is that uh public institutions do
make respondents feel that they are
they are taken care of and provided with
a certain good standard of living
in terms of unlovable aspects of
relationships with public institutions
i think this might not be quite
surprising to many people
i there are some common themes here
around feeling
a sense of a lack of
safe space for disagreement or a lack of
opportunity
to give feedback that is heard of
the feeling of over curation over
regulation
and all of this leading to a sense of
disempowerment
we saw this unpacked quite a lot when we
did our
qualitative interviews
our respondents actually helped us to
understand
lack of empowerment in in different ways
so one could be
people feeling that oh yeah i can't i
can't change anything
i'm just as uh i'm just one person
some some others told us that you know
they they feel that they have no part
to play and change because they're they
don't feel a sense of ownership
or they may want to advocate for change
but
uh have a have a feeling of fear
or trepidation and then
others also feel like okay they may want
to have change but they don't know how
to start
and they don't know what viable
alternatives might be
so saying on this point a little bit
this is something that we are really
hoping to unpack
during the panel discussion especially
the topic on
how we can design for a sense of
ownership and agency
okay in conclusion so is singapore
livable or not
so i think uh we could say that 69
of our respondents feel that singapore
is mostly livable
and completely lovable uh five percent
feel that singapore is definitely not
livable
i think what's interesting to us is that
quite a significant
uh percentage of the respondents over a
quarter
actually um are you know undecided that
singapore is neither livable nor
unlovable
we will go on to the panel discussion
and
i would like to introduce our our
panelists
okay so first we have mr delisha kula
surya
executive director of deloitte center
for the edge
uh delisha is also our knowledge partner
for
the lovable singapore project so could i
invite panelists uh when i read out your
names too
also please turn on your cameras so that
the audience can see you
next we've got don coordinating director
partnership projects office at the
at mccy so she also spearheads the
singer
the singapore together movement
and singapore together is also one of
our partners for the project
next we have professor heng chai kyung
provost chair director of center for
sustainable asian cities at nus
who is also our project partner
next up is mr tongy executive director
of common ground
who is our design singapore council
board member
and last but not least dr adrian hua
director
futures office office of the president
at nus
so we invited dr kwa because of his
pioneering work
in the intersection of futures public
policy
and education so i'd like to kick start
the direction uh the discussion with don
who has been running the emerging
stronger conversations
for the past few months uh don would you
like to talk about uh some commonalities
that you've seen
in the loveable singapore study and the
emerging stronger conversations
yeah i'd be glad to janine and thank you
and welcome everyone to this
a really interesting webinar and i love
the work that
the design singapore council is doing on
the livable singapore idea so as i
as i read your slides and heard you give
this presentation
and picking up some of the key ideas
around what people felt made singapore
lovable and what made singapore
unlovable what really struck me is
uh some of these were so common to what
we also heard from singaporeans
through the emerging stronger
conversations so these conversations
happened
they we kicked it off last year in the
heart of
covet 19 to engage singaporeans in a
conversation about their covert
experience
and also to hear their hopes and their
ideas about how singapore can emerge
stronger
and what they told us has just been put
out in our report in
february and you can go to uh www.sg
emerging stronghold conversations to
have a look at it but some of the things
that were similar to what the lovable
singapore project has uncovered include
things like
on the unlovable side singapore's very
stressful and what kovit taught us
is actually we can slow down the pace
and people enjoyed that that space to
breathe
they discovered parts of singapore they
didn't know there before
people enjoyed the time to connect with
their families
this idea about singaporeans being very
judgmental and
quick to give their opinion and not
necessarily thinking too hard
before they offered an opinion also came
up and there was an invitation i think
for singapore person think about how we
can be a bit more
accommodating of each other's views and
then on the lovable side i hear the
words around being
singaporeans being gracious considerate
caring inclusive and generous
and that really was what singaporeans
told us they saw during covet
all of us would have seen examples of
singaporeans from all walks of life just
stepping forward to do something to help
their community their neighbor
people in need and that was what
singaporeans saw that they really
appreciated and wanted to see more of
going forward so that was what really
struck me there was a
fair bit of overlap between what we had
heard in the emerging strong
conversations
and in your project as well
thanks don next i would like to call on
uh
adren to talk about the nuances
um between uh a city and a nation in
terms of
looking at livability uh adrian also has
uh
previously brought up an interesting
question about it's not just
you know we think about lovability it's
not just about whether we love the city
but
whether the city loves us back and i
think a lot of what he looks at
riffs off what don just said earlier so
handing the time over to you adrian
great uh thanks very much uh hi everyone
thanks for having me here
um so first of all let me just say that
it's so important to have this
conversation right now because
you know so much of our singapore
narrative is framed in terms of um
fear insecurity scarcity even paranoia
and forget that throughout
there has always been hope and
solidarity and love so i think this
conversation is very
important to have right now but here we
are talking about love and lovability
and lovingness and all these things
and this in this age of um messiness and
contestation and we should also at the
same time be not so um
naive to expect that all our discussions
and all conversations will culminate in
some
uh finality some some kumbaya moment so
you know in the interest of uh
in acknowledging the the messiness
what i'd like to do now is to introduce
some uh messiness and
contest some of the terms that we've
been using
throughout so in as much as we ring our
hands about
whether singapore is lovable or
unlovable and and we also at the same
time need to ask whether
that which is the object of our desire
if it loves us back and i think there
are also many layers to peel back so
you know uh you could be lovable
and loved and that's awesome and that's
no
magical um and at the same time it could
be unlovable and unloved and that's
poetic justice so you kind of deserve it
but i think the other two possibilities
are rather interesting to consider
um you know you could be lovable and yet
be strangely unloved and at the same
time you are actually
rather unlovable but strangely enough
you're quite lost
and how enough did that happen so when
you talk about
unlovable or lovability and and all
manner of uh
permutations of that term you also kind
of need to ask
what manner of love are we talking about
right so i noticed that the title of
this project is
uh to our city with love and you're
talking about singapore as the city
but we are both a city and a nation
state that perhaps
love in these two different contexts uh
means different things so when we talk
about love are we talking about love as
a raging passion
right uh that speaks to singapore as a
city with all the messiness and the
dynamism and the flows and the chaos
and the fringe and the underside and and
all the things that
that gives the city the buzz or are we
talking about love
as a warm fuzzy steady burning furnace
that perhaps speaks to singapore as a
nation state right so in the sense of
asking is singapore the kind of place
that seduces you
and makes you want to be seduced or
singapore that comfortable place of
solace and predictability
kind of like the book that you read over
and over again yeah you know the plot
but you love the book and you're happy
to read it over and over again
or are we talking about the tough love
right
um the kind of city that you know
tells you uh the reality as it is and it
pulls no punches
so i think these are some of the things
that we really do need to consider and
we all love the place for different
reasons
um some of us love it for its prosaic
perfections and it's precisely that
makes other people hate it
uh and others of us love the place for
its perfect imperfections like the song
goes and yet
it's also the same the things that make
other people hate it
so i thought i'd just
surface some of these thoughts uh or the
all these
things through and i'd love to hear my
candidates uh
fellow panelists to see to hear what
they think about it so
thanks very much thanks adrian
so from different types of love uh i
think that kind of reminds me of
something that uh
he had spoken to us about in terms of
uh emotions and emotional scarcity
that occurs as a result of living
experiencing a pandemic and how that
actually affects the type of love that
we have
for the place that we live in so um
yeah i would like to invite you to
tell us more about that sure thanks
janine
yeah this is a quick shout out i just
noticed that uh old friend based the
chain is into
attendances hi sushi okay
um yeah i was i was really actually
echoing about
uh i was resonating with with the
results that the
the findings were sharing right as
as well as basically what adrian and don
was sharing um
i take to the to the optimism of
actually what
don was sharing about basically what
many people found
valuable about singapore post this
pandemic
um but i'm also self right understanding
that the pandemic revealed
i guess multiple different inequalities
in singapore
and um in that particular sense of
equality uh
inequality we took some time to just
understand families
in terms of who felt that um there were
they were part of families in which they
felt they loved
uh they they loved their families they
felt safe in their families and what
were the characteristics right they
began to just unders help them
feel that families itself were a good
place to be in
and we tried to look at families and
just extrapolate their understanding
um around love of you know having being
part of a loving family and a lovable
family
uh and take that and extend it into into
societies in general
and what we saw and it came down to was
this whole principle between
families that were breeding scarcity or
families that were holding abundance
um and the gist of it over here right
came down to three main themes that we
were seeing
the first one was the people who truly
begin to feel that they loved their
families who were ideas that they felt
they could belong in their families they
felt safe they feel loved
despite the strong diversity of views
within the family itself
and i thought that was fascinating in
seeing similar themes stuff within
singapore society itself
whether or not uh people find a sense of
belonging or whether they're simply
trying to fit in
um and i guess basically when it comes
down to push comes to shelf right and
resources are not enough and sometimes
we are
strapped for resources we always ask
ourselves who gets the pie and who
doesn't get the pie
do i have to necessarily fit in to be
able to get the pie
or do i get the pie you know even though
i'm different
um and i get to feel itself right i
truly belong
okay so that's one particular theme the
second over here was around families
when they felt that
um each member of the family were all
healthy and also contributing fairly
um so they were talking about you know
father's mothers or the lazy sister that
wouldn't contribute or some
some story like that over here right and
i found that again
uh the theme was very strong itself in
singapore society itself whether or not
we felt that you know we are part of
society where everybody
really contributes fairly whether or not
everybody itself
is really healthy to begin to to
contribute
and doing so over here i think uh one of
the big themes around
singapore the whole stressful singapore
part right is that a lot of the stress
forces priority in this
when we have limitation of time we feel
strapped
and whether or not we can choose to love
despite all that need for priority
the third theme that we are seeing over
here in the last theme
was an idea that the families themselves
actually gave opportunity they gave
an empowerment and this is actually
echoing a lot itself with
you what you guys have found within your
your own service whether people felt
disempowered whether they felt itself
right they really had a sense of
ownership
uh in all this diversity that we're
seeing so those were three themes right
that
that come up and uh it came down to
primarily itself unfortunately
we would have to say to mindsets to
attitudes to whether or not people were
in their own language
uh bringing about more abundance within
the family systems or just feeding
scarcity
uh yeah there and it was a very much a
linguistic experience
from for many of them but those are the
things itself that i was echoing with
and what our own field of work is is
revealing to us
yeah thank you
nicely actually we've been talking a lot
about um
emotional uh impact with regards to
the question of lovability and i'd like
to kind of like take the conversation
into something a little bit more
tangible uh talking about place making
and which is something that i think paul
kane can um tell us more about
so what was the role of place making in
engendering
or enhancing livability
especially uh being a project partner uh
how do you feel about you know seeing
the results
uh that were shared just now so i'll
propping over to you
well perhaps i should um follow up on
what was just
some of the themes mentioned earlier um
especially in regards to covet 19
and all the efforts of the uh the
work that uh selflessness of
our neighbors our citizens contributing
different
manners um well that's very heartwarming
and in fact one of the uh
i think a few things about environment
that sort of probably make that possible
or make that
more easy um is that
number one we
for some reason have provided right
incidentally um
maybe in the way we play in our
environment especially uh
the density right
it makes it makes helping families in
need
um rather easier you go to
you go to a new town you can help a lot
of families
as opposed to um the kind of very low
density environments where
you have to drive you have to whatever
so here and
and and so i think our environment makes
it
easier to to help out many many families
all at once
um the other thing is that you need
space
you need space for things to happen
right you need space too
so i see on tv people packing
packing all this boxes all these
packages all these bags you need space
and
they can do it in a public space in the
void decks
all sorts of places and and again this
is something that
uh well through our planning through our
the way we plan our new towns etc
we created all these spaces which now
comes to good use
and and perhaps when it comes to um
[Music]
place making um again in this uh
what korean 19 has really shown us is
that uh
public space community space and
open spaces parks
town centers etc becomes very much
sought after
people if if there's a it has a
choice you rather dying um
alfresco or any open air rather than
within
a a restaurant um and um
so this this places uh becomes very
important and i think in this episode of
kovit 19 it shows us um and probably
we'll talk more about it later on
the importance of um public space of
comedy spaces
within our new towns within our
neighborhoods
yeah i'll well let me just
stop here uh i'm sure we'll have more
time to talk about the importance of
this
uh and other other um tangible
physical stuff thanks
so last we have doneesha who is a very
special person because he has actually
journeyed with us
on this lovable singapore study almost
practically from day one
and i think we we hit the circuit
breaker together and had to you know
change the entire approach of the study
together so having heard you know all
all the panelists some
insights about both the tangible and
intangible aspects of livability
i'd actually like to ask you um
something
as a as our knowledge partner how do you
think you know
what kind of implications do all of
these have on
you know the post pandemic lovable
singapore what would we do with all
these findings
and well when you joined us as a
knowledge partner
what was your vision for this project
um yeah thank you janine for having me
along for this whole journey it's been
very interesting to say the least
so just as a context for the for the
audience
we moved here in june 2019 from the u.s
and so we had six months on the ground
before covet hit
and the initial planning and everything
was around and we were so excited about
meeting people live having kind of
physical interactions
observing them in the natural habitat
and then coveted so everything had to
fundamentally change so
we have to recognize in some part that
the results that they're getting
is uh with the backdrop of a year in
lockdown
right so it may not be if you were to
run these uh
surveys and studies on a ongoing basis
year or year you might find different
results
but we found a lot of things uh
affirming and i think what we saw at
covid is something that we can all
relate to individually
uh it's a concentration right it
many of us felt stressed at one point or
the other other through that because we
were more confined we had less options
we felt stuck you couldn't get out um
and other points
if we found space for reflection
it was a crisis right in many ways and
that gave point for reflection um
i'm sure many of you found that you
spend more time with your family than
you ever had
as strong you mentioned and there are
many lovable paths to it and some
unlovable paths to that too right
this is the most time i spent with my
family
as long as i've had a family um
so i think we're emerging to uh a
post-pandemic
time now as we emerge from this we're
not going to bounce
back to everything being the same some
things will change
forever right work going to work how we
work
is going to change fundamentally it's
going to be yes a bit of a transition
but it's not going to transition back to
what it was before
you know there's there's a group i'm
part of in facebook the
singapore hiking group pro uh
pre-pandemic is 2 000 people
now it's like 72 000 people and
i don't know whether they were hiking
before and they just got on it
to exchange images and to showcase or
whether this was pushed by
bicycle sales have tripled over the last
few months right so
many of us might have included saw many
parts of singapore
that we never would have for years so
there are some things that i hope are
going to continue
and with that comes a heightened desire
at least for myself personally to be in
nature more and i think that's reflected
in some of the studies and
all the comments from the panelists to
be in community more and what does
community mean
and i think we have to tackle the fact
that some things are allowable for some
are unlovable for others
the example uh that janine pointed out
of hey people you know drinking and
making noise
that to me is quite lovable that's kind
of people enjoying themselves but
to my in-laws that was quite unlovable
ah so uncouth
so loud right and that and i think
that's reflected by many
someone's asking whether it's an over 45
thing i'm over 45.
um so i think we're not going to bounce
back to the same i think we've had the
points of reflection and i'm hoping i'm
really hoping that everyone on this call
and many others
would engage in act in the workshops to
design
a more lovable singapore because we need
all those voices
to to make something that is allowable
for us many people at least at some
point
thanks alicia so you know originally
when i was uh designing this um
so-called very lovable uh webinar uh
delicious comments would have cycled us
very nicely and
smoothly into the next topic which was
on the design that post pandemic love
ability in singapore
uh unfortunately uh mentee meter didn't
feel the same way
or i i failed to uh activate it
correctly though
i think now i am going to try to share
screen
uh with mentimeter and let's see the
results of um
the first poll
okay here goes nothing all right
okay i think it is showing
okay cool awesome sigh of relief
all right so um just now we kind of
asked everyone to
let us know whether the so-called top
factors in both
loveability and unlovability resonated
with with
you personally so like you know um
during the surveys we found that top
factor for lovable places
is being able to spend time there with
your loved ones and take a breather from
everyday life
and you agree with that so i think that
that met with a lot of agreement uh both
in terms of the lovable places and
top factors for unlovable places so
that seems to align very well with what
our audience feels
in terms of um
singapore identity and culture what's
lovable and unlovable
oh i think top factors were unlovable
singapore
identity and culture stressful place of
life into this and materialistic culture
i think that
resonated the least with our audience
right now
that would be interesting to unpack in
terms of behavior
surprisingly many people i think agree
that being
law abiding friendly and having strong
community bonds
is um resonates with them
similar to unlovable behavior
and top factors were lovable public
institutions so
i think quite clear agreement okay top
factors were unlovable public
institutions
it's a bit surprising to me that um
not that it's not like uh more that
the audience is not more strongly in
agreement that these are the
factors that cause unlovability
i'm wondering if any of our panelists
would like to comment on
what they're seeing so uh
tulisha i'm seeing you we would we would
type in because tony found out it was
actually not
72 000 or 7200 for hiking
but there were 32 000 for wildlife
spotting
so people are still outdoors a lot
uh looking at this i don't see any any
big
surprises where's the law abiding on did
that come up again
so that means um i mean i would say like
a major
uh more than half of our audience agreed
that these are indeed uh lovable
behavior
to them i'm kind of surprised that um
the part about the unlovable public
institutions
i i thought there would be more
agreement that there is
a lack of space for this agreement
there's too many laws
and regulations and um
there's not enough opportunities to be
heard but
currently the the slider is at 3.5
um yeah don what do you think i mean
from your emerging stronger
experience does this line up
well in a way it does because through
the emerging strong conversations there
were quite a number of
themes that came up and this question
of i guess um you know to what extent do
we engage each other
whether it's public institutions or just
you know just civic participation in
general
it was a key issue but probably not one
of the
top top ranked issues the ones that
people cared about the most
were around you know social support and
what what
our values what do we stand for this
point about uh
being able to spend time and take a
breather definitely was one of the
values kind of points that came up so
there is some
alignment i would say yeah and i guess
what i
uh i'm reflecting on also having heard
the various
panelists fee is that
to be to even be able to say
uh i love singapore because of this and
i
find singapore unlovable because of this
actually there's something very
cathartic about it
and the process of being able to
articulate what's unlovable
can actually be part of the lovable
process if
if i'm making sense you know this
process of inviting criticism
can be part of making something lovable
yes i that's that's a point that i have
never considered and i think
it's very true and i hope this is
something we can unpack both
today and uh in the subsequent workshops
that we're running
to zero in on what we can do in
you know certain areas of strong
unlovability
so actually uh on this note i'm gonna
i'm gonna get our audience to do another
poll
before we move into the discussion on
uh you know how kobe has impacted
our sense of love for singapore or how
we
have felt love from singapore
and i am really really hoping it works
again
okay so i hope everyone can see a purple
screen in front of you
so yeah if you just go to menke.com and
use the code there
you should come to this purple screen
which
asks you on how your outlook on the
following
has changed as a result of your
experiences during covet
so you i believe you can rank it in
order of importance
so we're curious to know whether um
having
experienced a pandemic for
well a year now has your view on
whether singapore is an inclusive
society change has your personal
aspirations changed your willingness to
contribute to singapore society
your willingness to contribute to your
community um
your view on what good governance is and
oh
wow okay i can see the results now
and the last one is view on national
identity
okay so i think what has changed most
is certainly um oh
things are moving okay i'm just gonna
give it some time to settle down
okay uh
inclusivity has come up tops
yeah i think that's probably something
that actually oh no
now start
interesting
okay all right let's let's uh let's
close up the polls now so that we
we can have you know some discussion
okay so let's close up the post now uh
i'd like to direct my first question to
you
about inclusivity so just now you talked
a little bit about you know uh the
experience of different families
during covet you know abundance versus
scarcity
um yeah what what do you think is
happening here when uh
you know our audience is saying that
their view on whether singapore as an
inclusive society
has changed and and maybe i should also
add in
uh from our own surveys we got
quite a few responses about how um
people felt disappointed
especially with regards to the treatment
of
the foreign workers and also their own
um
observations of how kovit has had a far
more uh uterus impact on
lower income segments yeah
yeah the the at least what we're
noticing from our side over here is that
really
it's it's a generational thing um the
whole idea of inclusion
is very much maybe i think uh a more
stronger theme itself for those who have
fought maybe 40 and below
uh to put it generously um and i've met
multiple different groups over here that
really cannot fathom what this inclusion
thing is about
uh they they don't really get it so
there's some parents over here that just
have not
actually within their own social circles
express enough diversity to understand
what people are so
upset about um yeah and
i think there is that still that strong
sense over here that oh you know
what's what's everybody getting so so so
worked up about around this whole idea
of diversity
and inclusion and um so the diversity
around anything from personality to
ideas of introverts to
gender equality and things like that
right it's very much a generational
thing so the
the the spiking up of the emotion right
and the strong
intensity of emotions that's attached to
it yeah seems to be a lot in terms of
uh new language that's coming from
overseas as well as basically a language
among ourselves that
what was typically under the table
before now has platform by which to be
heard
um and there are multiple different
themes over especially coming from the
minority races
uh coming out you just say simply say
that you know no longer will be silent
we really wish that you would understand
and hear why is it
we don't feel included even though you
know we have racial harmony today
um so that is that's something that
that's coming up
yeah uh but really when we when we do
this work itself right uh
intel inter-generational one you can see
there's always this like
a furrowed brow coming from the older
generations like what are you talking
about
they absolutely don't get it yeah uh
i i suspect though it's a theme to stay
uh if it's really coming from younger
generation it's gonna be in singapore at
least for a good
next 20 30 years or so yeah so i would
pay attention to it
i think what you said uh absolutely hits
the nail on the head when we look at
uh you know our data and and break it
down by
age group inclusivity does tend to be
something that you know a certain
generation the younger generation
thinks about more um or or rather
that inclusivity in terms of um you know
like uh
sexual sexual orientation um
ethnicity the older generation we saw
were more concerned about inclusivity in
terms of uh you know physical access
to spaces and actually on this note um
there's this really interesting question
from the audience which i would like to
bring up and maybe propping an adrian
might want to answer it
so i'll read out the question uh from
romelu so this is for all panelists
uh he says he actually sorry i find it
lovable that we
somewhat consider inclusiveness issues
in designing our living space
however as we ask ourselves who have
been missed out
could we have ironically missed out the
question of
mi in the picture say for accessibility
and mobility issues
often times we frame those issues from
the perspective of wheelchair users
but by doing that we neglect children
with school bags on wheels
the couples pushing infants in prams the
elderly who shop with 20 bags and you
and i as well
who enjoy traveling and using luggages
which come with wheels
could we have missed according due
according to gravity accessibility and
mobility issues
and missed the opportunity to make our
living space even more lovable
should we have seen ourselves in the big
picture of accessibility and
mobility issues and it ends up by asking
do we need to love ourselves
more as we love others okay
all right uh propping would you like to
take a step that this i think is a
really interesting and unusual question
about designing spaces for inclusivity
well thanks for this uh i think yes
thanks for this question
um indeed i think when we design our our
spaces
we have to we have to think of all sorts
of people
with all all manners of
mobility right um so
i agree i agree entirely that we have to
think of the
uh three-year-old toddler to the 35 year
old
grandmother and um and in between and
everybody in between so um yes we have
codes for
universal accessibility etc but i
i think more than more than that it is
also
for designers and planners to really to
really understand
a behavior understand people's behavior
understands people's use of space
and uh and plan accordingly so
yes of course we plan our space to be
complete spaces to be uh
inclusive um uh
what i what i wanted to say earlier on
um
maybe since we talked a lot a lot about
lovability
uh i and i and i in my earlier remark
i should have said that you know
we we must plan our environment such
that
it offers opportunities of all different
segments of
all segments of society to really
realize the potential
because i see in here also this um
in your in your in your survey here
personal aspirations
right um once you
we should plan our environment to allow
for that
so for example when we talk about the
covet 19 earlier on
if if my meaning if i if i find meaning
and purpose in serving others right in
volunteering
i must be able to find space to direct
right be the void deck be the be the a
space
that uh you know hdb environment
somewhere
that i can i can do so and and space
allows to do that
so um if if i find
um purpose and meaning in meeting
friends for
line dancing i must be able to find
place to do that
and and so on so forth so different
people find
um fulfillment in different things and
and being able to
being able to um realize that i think
make them love
their city even more
this this comes back to the part basis
stressful singapore
yes it's stressful um especially for
work but
different people over the the 20 the
weekend
or the evenings the 20 of the time where
they they don't work
will find um various activities
um to to relax um
to derive meaning purpose etc and we
should provide
those places yeah okay i stopped there
thanks over to you yeah so um
you know one of the pitfalls of speaking
of the professor is that you're just
sitting there crossing off the things
that you wanted to say
because it's really said them so i
really agree with a lot of what now
changing
said i would just simply add that
you know as singapore becomes a more
complex place and things become more
tightly coupled
and there are so many other interests in
play as compared to
when years ago we are never going to get
it right the first time if at all
uh but i think society says something
about the mindset that we have right the
expectation that
uh there will be a wave of some or that
might be a wave of a magic wand and that
we can
accomplish lovability or deal with the
questions of
access and inclusivity via policy or
administrative
dicta that's only i think in today's
context can only ever be a partial
explanation for it
we do have to give space for a messy
emergence to take place
many of these answers will come
as trial and error as a result of
negotiation as a result of contestation
sometimes polite sometimes not
but you know that part of growth as part
of the evolution of society
and love is one of the things that grows
and evolves
adrian can i add to that i think there's
a there's a question from
in the q a about why are we even
studying loveability when most
singaporeans say it's
most reliable and i think it adds to
what you said what tonya said don said
that we're starting the discourse it
starts it is going to be messy but just
even asking the questions and even
getting people to reflect on it
and and respond is part of the
part of the part of what we need to do
here right as designing a different
world
as tony said when you talk to these
older
folk they might say i don't even
understand what you're talking about but
hopefully
it now is something that they might
reflect or think about
right so i i think we have to give
ourselves some credit for just
even starting the conversation no and by
the way
this is a conversation not only locally
that we started the conversation
globally this is not something that is
spoken about much so
i like that singapore's leading english
no indeed right um many of these things
that many of these words that we use
we use them loosely they mean different
things to different people
but if we can't even come together to
even talk about what exactly we mean by
these terms
then we know it and this this is uh this
is a good start
and it may be that we will have
perpetual beginnings and more beginnings
and more beginnings and this will never
end
and that's fine that's fine yeah
and there's another question uh related
to this saying who do you want to
participate in this study and why in
terms of designing it
and i would say it's people not like us
we need to hear from because we already
have opinions we already have our input
into the study we need to hear from
those who are not like us
and get their voice into into this as
well but
jenny and you should probably uh point
on that
actually uh before i point on that i
actually think
this is a really good opportunity to
shift
our conversation towards actually the
second topic which is
you know it's just coming up more and
more which is how we can actually
uh design for a sense of ownership and
agency
and that is exactly what we have been
talking about all night actually the
whole um
uh movement towards designing that
post-pandemic lovable
singapore um that that endeavor to bring
together diverse
voices and you know redesign
spaces and and behavior and experiences
that make singapore more lovable
actually that won't come about
until people actually feel that their
efforts
and their voices and uh
their their inputs uh will be heard or
or they feel empowered to co-create or
take some kind of action
in the first place and on that note
actually there's a really
interesting question um in
in the q a uh which is about shifting
narratives
and that that can be a pretty
interesting
place to start this conversation so how
can we shift
the singapore narrative from like fear
and scarcity
uh which came up you know in
relationships to
public institutions towards like towards
satisfaction
and maybe just and maybe beyond
satisfaction right maybe also
empowerment yeah um does anyone wanna
take up this uh
rather uh complex question
okay why don't i buy uh
no as i looked at some of the survey
results that you just did a few minutes
ago and
when you start to realize that um
they really aren't as binary as we think
they are
right some of the unlovable traits that
we see
are the shadow side of the lovable
traits so
a lovable trait is that singapore is law
abiding and
safe and and all the things that come to
associate singapore and that's
fantastic um
feel it steroids push it a little bit it
tips over into being judgy
and and you know in the law abiding
sticker for rules person could be the
one to
rustle up the lynch mob and like the
torches and hound people who have
computer transactions
so you know so it's not really an
either or thing many of the things that
we find unlovable
about singapore are actually aspects of
us which are actually quite lovable
but taken to an extreme uh and maybe
it's a function of time as well the
context shifts
uh certainly not speaking about myself
but
you know a person with an adorable trait
or quality some years ago might find
that that same trait today is much
despised and
found to be extremely irritating
speaking
hypothetically of course and so it could
be for singapore as well
right the thing that was extremely
adorable and attractive and
much love in the context uh
becomes uh hated despised
you know scorned at uh in a different
context and it's different for different
groups different people and i think this
is something that we do need to
accommodate and and we will never ever
accommodate it perfectly there will
always be uh jagged pieces
right we're not a jigsaw puzzle that's
going to fit perfectly we are dragging
pieces
sometimes we fit nicely and sometimes we
just
not robbing each other the wrong way
actually on this note right um
i want to kind of go back a little bit
to something that we
talked about earlier um with regards to
empowerment and participation
and i think dawn mentioned earlier
that uh actually not not everybody wants
to be
involved not everybody wants to
necessarily feel
uh this need to you know co-create and
and design this uh whatever this new
lovable
uh singapore isla and i and i think
there's some kind of connection to what
adrian just mentioned so
it's it's actually a very nuanced issue
right this whole
concept of co-creation and empowerment
and i was just wondering what your your
thoughts on on this are
yeah thanks janine uh let me let me have
a go at this um
you're right that based on our sense
of uh the people living here in
singapore
there's a group of people who really
want to be involved and want to
be activated and take charge and be part
of any process that you open up to them
and there are those that may not be want
to be involved but they want to know
that we're engaging each other that
there's ways to be involved if they wish
to be
and then there's a group that i think
you know when we talk about um
fear and scarcity uh it's it's a real
thing right because
there are people who are just trying to
make each day work
and just trying to pull it together and
really being
participative in a civic kind of sense
is not a priority
and that's okay um hearing adrian speak
brings to mind
a body of work by a guy called barry
johnson called polarity management
that's the idea that you know the the
light and shadow the the two ends of a
spectrum the both and not the either or
so um i think where singapore needs to
go
uh going forward is to bring the two
ends of the spectrum together people
across a whole bunch of
perspectives together so that we hear
from each other
so that we know that when we make a
choice this is what we gain
and this is what we might lose and who
are the people that gain and who are
people that lose
and it's having those conversations to
broker common space and even if the
common space is never found at least
you know someone who has a different
point of view than you
i think that really is the way forward
if
you know singapore's to get past uh
fear and scarcity to be able to see the
whole
i mean as an outsider can i point out
that
as a narrative singapore breeds fear and
scarcity as a
way of driving nationalism at least at
the outside in point of view
so i think this has to be a little bit
more top down if you actually want to
evolve that i think there's precisely
one
one question that has popped up in the
in the q a about um
uh the the role of of the government in
all of this right
when we did the when we went out to do
the surveys and the interviews about
liveable singapore we did get some kind
of
interesting responses uh where you know
our respondents tell us oh um public
agency
is running a so-called ground-up
initiative to study loveability is that
is is that weird is that uh ironic so
there's this question um
in the in the q a about
uh how will the post pandemic recovery
period
change singapore's trust in the
government what is it at stake i think
we can probably expand that a little bit
to
talk about what what is this new like
relationship between
public institutions and and people and
what was changing in in terms of how
people want to be
engaged and how people want to be um
yeah to be brought on board
well i think like any relationship um
singapore citizens relationship with
singapore is evolving as well right
as a singapore as a as a nation and as a
government
so all these things are evolving at the
same time not everyone wants the same
things that they wanted before not
everything it has to be what it was
before
and that's why i
think at least some portion of the
population
wants to see a shift in narrative and
others
are happy with it as it is and saying
it's you know
it this is for all things considered
this is this is good and this is worth
it
um when again once again at the outside
endpoint of you said i'd love to hear
more from um those who have been here
longer
and and understand this better maybe
i'll
i'll have a go it is um delisha you're
saying you're speaking from the point of
outsider point of view about cider
i mean yes uh and
and you see a sliver of the society
and the reality is every everybody's
reality is very different
the person who's 85 years old and a
person who's 25 years old has a very
different perspective
the person who's retired 85 years old
unfortunately this is the person who
retires with uh
with very little in his bank right i
mean
oops uh can you hear me
yeah yeah okay and my battery
went low so there's a person who i mean
um
i i'm always aware that um uh
you know the pioneer generation probably
when they retire that uh
their salary a lot of them no more than
700 bucks
for a month you know um and our
and whoever dies in in this particular
uh
uh webinar we are
faced we are from the middle middle
income
right um and
our salary our monthly salary
is many many force um the
the the salary of the person who retired
20 years ago
and his reality today is very different
from the reality of
a 40-year person or 25 year old person
so
you know from this this narrative of
changing from scarcity and fear whatever
um to satisfaction yes it may it may be
applicable for certain segment of the
population but also segment of
population i agree with dawn
um it's very very different and so
and that's a i mean that's the destiny
of a country like ours
that has developed so fast over the last
40 years last 50 years that we have
both ends of the spectrum right um
so we are at this at the same time a
much
well i won't say a mature economy but a
[Music]
a developed economy but with a very long
tail
um and and how to make these different
segments of
population love singapore and love our
city
um takes very different means
i'll stop there i mean people these
different segments of society have very
different see things differently
and find things livable and find
different things
livable for some it takes very little
for others you know everything may be
taken from granted
right okay i'll stop here
we've only got a few more minutes left
but i want to do something very uh
selfish
and kind of ask the panelists to answer
questions
that have highlighted contradictions in
our study
so that when we write our report uh we
will have all these answers ready
uh yeah the first one is
from yvonne uh what is your
interpretation of people finding law
being law abiding a lovable trait and
yet at the same time
finding um regulations and
and laws from institutions unlovable
quite a difficult question does anybody
want to
to take it up so i'll have a goal
and i don't have a magic answer but i
think it speaks to the point about
polarity i mentioned earlier right
so the polarity here i suppose putting
it roughly is this idea of
freedom but of course that's a good and
we all want freedom
but it's also um order i suppose on the
other end
we all can value that as well and
singapore of course i guess some
navigates this space in a particular way
and maybe we lean more towards the order
side maybe a little bit less on the
freedom side
and so we're all finding that balance
and that balance will shift from issue
to issue and
from time to time and i guess all
societies have to find that that balance
uh what i wanted to link to uh is this
point about
you know profing was talking about the
different groups of people
and i had earlier talked about the need
to bring different voices together so
that we're not
just staying within our own uh
circles or a narrow point of view
um and the idea that comes to mind is uh
in in i guess social theory there's this
notion about
bonding social capital and bridging
social capital so bonding is
people that are like you and you you get
to know them better different
relationships and that's bonding capital
is a good thing of course and
so for instance in my case people of my
age group people of my gender perhaps
but bridging social capital is is where
you work
across the boundaries right and you're
trying to get a
connections with people very different
from yourself and so i think for me
just you know where singapore needs to
go is building a lot more on that
bridging social capital and that's how
we will unlock things like
the freedom and the order and navigating
that space in a way that brings
people together rather than brings
people apart
can i just add on to whatever john said
because
you know in asking the question it
reminds me of how
every time we say it's unfair we only we
really mean it's unfair to me
but when it's unfair in my favor we
never complain about it so i think
that's
a little bit of an element going on as
well we love the laws
until they impinge on us or stop us from
doing what we really want to do so i
think there's
certainly an element of that going on
there
so i'll just quickly jump in and just
talk about the distinction between
laws and norms that i think lower the
hierarchy of needs when talking about
safety and security a lot of the laws
support our safety and security
but in the whole world towards you know
belonging and self-actualization a lot
of the norms actually
um work against us yeah in that whole
sense of holding a
container diverse enough to hold all the
differences within singapore
so i think no one has any issue itself
with the fact that actually we are
a safe country um it's whether or not we
actually have an inclusive country that
i think people are pushing up against
it's the norm's line it's not the laws
thanks yee actually there are so many
like really really great uh questions in
the
in the q and a box unfortunately i've
realized that with a bit of a shock
actually that it's
now 7 31 and we are actually officially
one minute
over time um i i think all these are
really
fantastic questions and you know if our
panelists actually don't mind
we can compile them and maybe you know
put together
uh you know short answers to to some of
the
some of the com the questions that are
coming up quite frequently
um if that's okay if everyone we can
follow up
this way yeah so actually uh
i would like to now um kind of bring
bring this slide back up which talks
about
our workshop you know co-creating a a
livable singapore and i think that
obviously uh segways very nicely from
all all the conversation about
what what the next step is after this
lovable
singapore study is done what do we
what do we do with the data uh well
is it gonna sit somewhere and not be
looked at
i think that would be a nightmare for
all of us who have labored through this
for more than a year so there are
actually three dates on the screen right
now
and we will be identifying um
areas of high unlovability or want of a
better phrase
and facilitating some brainstorming
sessions around them
so if you are able to join us you would
be very very welcome
too i'll just scan the qr code here
and i think on this note i will thank
our speakers
for you know sharing their evening with
us sharing their insights
candidly and and openly
and i think uh the conversation has been
very exciting as i can see
uh some comments on the chat as well um
also thank you to the audience and and
everyone for being so patient
you know with the tech booboo just now
i've been uh informed that it was
entirely
my fault i was uh i was the one who put
the wrong code so yes actually it's me
like
i blame manti meter but actually it's
media so yes uh apologies again
uh i hope you you can please feel free
to vent in our event survey
or which is the qr code on the left yeah
please feel free to you know talk about
talk about that uh but also give us
another chance you know on the right you
can see casting hope right so we are
really hoping that you will uh you know
come back for more
uh national design center events and
activities so scan the qr code on the
right
for that and on that note uh thank you
so much for being with us this evening
um we will we will reach out to
everybody who signed up
with a link to the online record to the
recording that we put online
and also further down the road in a few
in a couple of months time when the
final report is ready
we will also reach out to share it with
everybody and
quite possibly there'll be another
similar event organized around it
so yes on that note thank you very much
and have a good evening
thank you very much thank you thank you
everyone
that's more inviting thank you